[Music]
So, uh, the guy comes in, right? And you
gota you have to deal with this shoulder
>> and this elbow. So what here's what I
mean.
>> Okay. The arm can go like that
>> and the arm can go like this.
>> Do do you understand?
>> So because the arm can go like that.
The initial inertia goes.
So there's that elbow and it allows me
to go around you. Do you see? Okay.
What the what the feduka does is always
go oh he's going back. Do you see how I
stop? I stopped here.
>> Okay.
>> If you if you pay attention we go again.
We go again and I stopped here. Do you
see? Stay there. Where you where we
stop? I stopped here. So you got to ask
the question what's making me stop here?
Do do you understand?
>> Does everyone understand that? Okay.
Because that's how you expose the the
Federite UKI. It's like you see why did
I stop here? So you're there. Could I
keep going? Yeah, I can keep going. Yes,
I can keep going. Do you see? And that's
what came out when he did you. Okay. So
if I'm here like that, you got to pay.
Yeah. Do you see? You can't do that.
Okay.
>> So this arm is dead. Not trying to do
that.
It's not your behavioral cue because the
guy will wrap around you there. Okay.
So, the arm goes dead and I go here.
Do do it two ways. I pull this. That's
the behavioral cue that the Fedite UK
does to stop going forward. Okay. But a
guy who was doing real chem would wrap
around you.
The behavioral cue was just trying to
pull him backwards. You see? Like that.
>> So I have to not pull you backwards.
The arm just dies. Boom.
Boom.
It's that little turn.
>> Arm dies. Boom. Attack
base.
Okay.